you
I do remember
a little bit he did he worked in
corporate when he was at GE and it is
really with great sadness that that I'm
here today in his memorial and I'm sure
he was a great colleague and friend so
you have my sincere regrets so you know
what I what I thought I'd do today
because I got very strict instructions
from your leadership team not to make
this a G commercial I'll do that in QA I
won't miss that I won't miss that
opportunity what I thought I'd do is uh
global about the world but talk mainly
about leadership what I view is kind of
some of the attributes of good leaders
of this generation and and and then let
you let the conversation go wherever you
want to take it so I think if your CEO
of a company that you have to have kind
of a point of view of what's going on in
the world and and you've got to invest
around what that point of view is so I
would say there's kind of five big
themes that that I think about from a
standpoint of running GE that you know
the first one is just the reordering of
the global economy you kind of see that
each and every day I joined you in 1982
in the decade of the 80s the developed
world really generated about 80% of the
economic growth in the next decade the
emerging markets developing world will
be 80% of the of the economic growth
with all the volatility that's in Europe
the big message is that Europe will be a
slower growth region you know my sense
is that these problems have a way of
getting solved but what it means is you
may have you know another five or ten
years of relatively slow growth in
Europe for a businessman of my
generation you I've already seen 25
years of slow growth in Europe so you
know you're a little bit conditioned for
what that might actually what that might
actually mean and aren't overly you know
I'd say we're all concerned but but
let's see that so reordering of the
global economy number one I'd say the
second big thing is just the the notion
of productivity and cost the whole
aspect and focus on having what I call
more products or more price points you
know as merging markets grow and even as
customers in the developed world have to
have to have you know lower cost
products we're going to have a lower
cost high quality generation of
oh geez and you've got to be able to
sell products at lower price points and
make good margins you know one of the
staples of our healthcare business is
NMR scanner that has certain field
strengths 1/2 Tesla and you know it
typically gets sold for 1/2 to 2 million
dollars in the vast majority of
applications you know we're developing a
product in China they can want to have
Tessa amar that can be sold for $500,000
and it's got 55 or 60 percent margins
and so you know you're going to have to
have a real sense for productivity
resource scarcity in some way shape or
form your generation is going to live
with with resource scarcity and what
that means two things really one is that
the resource rich parts of the world are
going to be quite interesting you know
no one should have to explain to any
businessperson
China and India today you know if you
don't already have that by the time you
get a Stanford Business School there's
not one thing I can do for you you know
fundamentally but places like Angola are
going to be quite interesting in your
lifetime you know the the stands
Kazakhstan Uzbekistan these are going to
be quite interesting there will be some
form of reemergence of Russia over the
next few years so a focus on both
resource rich parts of the world but
also on conservation technologies and
what do you do
post oil spill in the Gulf and how do
you how do you take on these big you
know kind of conservation economies are
going to be quite important so that's
that's the third thing the fourth thing
is just the notion of being a networked
world you know I don't say that I say
that post substantively from a
standpoint of what you can do from a
from an information technology
standpoint but also just the importance
of collaborations innovation joint
ventures you know a lot of what GE does
today in a growth standpoint is in the
form of joint ventures Intel and GE are
going to do a 50-50 joint venture in
home health we couldn't get there
necessarily on our own they couldn't get
there on their own but having the
ability to be networked and
collaborative from a substantive and
strategic standpoint is also is also
quite important and then the fifth one
is just
you know the state economy you you are
in a going to graduate from here with
the government intersecting more with
business than in the last 28 years of my
career you know basically when I joined
in 1982 there was a complete
disassembling of government impact on
business for almost 30 years whether the
Republicans get back into power in the
US this is unlikely going to stop in the
short term and then you add to that
Brussels I mean 60 percent of G's
outside the United States
Brussels Beijing all the other
governments in the world are quite
influential so this notion of being able
so so these are the five things we think
about as background in terms of how do
we plan our strategy and and and what do
we do and we take it very seriously from
a standpoint of how we view it now the
the lectures on leadership so that's why
I'm gonna spend the rest of my time
really talked about because I you know
my thesis is that leadership has almost
no shelf life that basically the things
you're learning you know while you're
here I hate to because you've showed out
a fortune for your education going to be
pretty irrelevant relat relat of lee
seun so you know it's a you know so you
have to be kind of thinking about what's
next and we spend about a billion
dollars as a company on education and we
kind of do it in four attributes my
first advice we spent a lot of time when
people join the company your career is
going to have to be deep first in broad
second the notion of leaving here as a
general manager is not going to happen
you've got to be good at something and
we want our people to be good at
something whether it's a function like
finance or marketing or whether it's a
business like wind power thing things
like that so you're going to build a
career that's deep first abroad second I
grew up in a generation where basically
people were taught general management
nothing is managed generally any more so
so I would say that is a very profound
difference between the world I grew up
in the world that you grew up in then we
do a lot of training on leadership and
I'll talk a little bit about some of the
traits that we tried but we try to match
the way we assess people and what we're
trying to train them on and we believe a
lot in continuing education and we learn
from others we study people as diverse
as Google and the US military academy to
get good techniques to how to train
leaders
then we rotate we've got 50 big pls
inside the company and we rotate them in
about every 18 months to do team-based
training how do you invest for growth
how do you make sure you win how you
benchmarking your competitors we make
sure to give every business kind of an
update on on on on leadership and and
how they execute better as a team and
then the fourth thing we do is a lot on
you know really the the predominant
theme for me right now in G is managing
a global enterprise so we work a lot on
the hardware and software of how do you
manage a company as diverse and like I
said we're we're probably a hundred
billion dollars outside the United
States I joined you in 1982 the whole
company was twenty four billion dollars
now we have 40 billion dollars just in
the emerging markets alone so it just
shows you kind of in one generation how
much a company can can change so that's
that's what we do one leadership so now
what I thought I'd do is just change
gears and kind of give you a you know
kind of ten things and I'm thinking
about visa vie what the next five or ten
years of leadership training leadership
development some things you ought to be
thinking about as you're leaving here
and starting your career and the first
one is what I would call analytical
listening analytical listening you know
why did the financial crisis happen what
could we who are running companies what
could we have not known and learned
about faster how can you do a better job
of kind of opening up outside forces and
still you know you know running a
company at the same time so analytical
listening surrounding yourself with
people you trust listening to them
matching with data and and working with
it in 2007 I was at the GE Capital Board
meeting and we saw a deal come in and it
had no in financial services and this
was a private equity firm that was going
to borrow money on a deal that they were
doing and they were able to get more
debt than the size of their deal there
were no covenants they could basically
reset the loan in 24 months right and I
said this is strange right this is not
the way capitalism was meant to work you
know and so we didn't improve the deal
and I hired Mackenzie and I
spent three million dollars with
McKenzie and said I want you to go study
is this liquidity massive liquidity
going to hat you know go on forever and
they came back sixty days later and said
absolutely this is so this is going to
happen you know don't worry about a
thing you got all these sovereign wealth
funds you got all this other stuff going
on so I tried to listen I swear you know
I really I really did but I think what
we've tried to do what we try to replace
that with is finding the people you know
finding the people the right critical
stuff about GE the naysayers who are the
naysayers out there and giving them a
voice inside the company and when I talk
about analytical listening I talk about
really having Red Team Blue team having
the people that are your worst critics
letting them inside where you are and
that you know that's a way that you have
to be break down the barriers of of how
you listen but I've never met one
successful person in any field of life
who wasn't a great listener who wasn't
curious about stuff and you're going to
have to have a career of leadership
that's all about that the second one is
adaptability and perseverance and just
being able to deal with volatility you
know this is just more volatile world
this is just a more volatile world I
mean we're dealing with you know there
hasn't been really a global business
person that's thought about Greece for
2,500 years right and now having fun
Philly now now man it's like friggin
Greece you got to be kidding me you know
so so you know there's something about
the world we live in
it's just more volatile it's it's
interconnected and so you know you want
to cover like mine that's got 285
thousand people it's 160 billion dollars
in revenue you've got to run it with an
operating plan you know yet yet the
world that your managers are dealing
with is just more volatile than it used
to be and
and you've got to find a way to buffer
your investors or your employees from
these wild swings and in volatility and
you know that's something that I think
you know quite important in the way you
know the way we try to do it is
recognized
you know just how volatile the world is
how adaptable you have to be and
there'll be businesses that basically I
run you know I run without an operating
plan for 2010
I have rough boundaries and where
they're going to go and then the other
businesses that I have tight controls
over and then in 2011 maybe the
businesses that didn't have as tight a
plan and 2010 will have a tighter plan
but but managing your careers and and
being managers that know how to how to
deal with adapt abilities really is
really good you know from - from 1982
until 2003 fundamentally the price of
oil was $15 a barrel the US economy
really grew for about four and a half
percent every year baby boomers from
their peak consumption period those were
twenty pretty good years I just think we
live in a generation now where about
every two or three years you are going
to be shocked you know I mean we I oh
you know we own NBC you know and seeing
when squawk box is on on Sunday night I
know something for hon but that's too
much too much volatility the third thing
is just the notion of managing and being
very open to managing relationships
connections a lot of you I don't know
how many people here will go to IT
startups and things like I'm sure it's
big chunk you can feel free to raise
your hand I'm not going to there's
nothing wrong okay I just was curious
but I mean you know you think about you
know technically trying to be Jesus
we've got a big installed base of
products and with sensing technologies
and information technology you know I I
basically know what every jet engine is
doing in the installed base in the fleet
right now you know I know the fuel
efficiency I know how its operating you
know we can kind of study how every CT
scanner is being used but being able to
know how to take this pervasive
information turn it into real knowledge
that is one aspect of just what what
your generation is going to have to know
how to do with the other piece is just
being a good partner and that's not only
to other companies but it's also
- you know the government you know
having an ability to purr to really
thrive and impact and be a you know know
how to manage relationships is going to
be very very important so you know I
think it's more seeing things from from
the other people's point of view it's
the willingness to to partner the
willingness to accept information on a
pervasive basis this whole area of the
network society I think is is quite
important
fourth knows how to simplify everything
knows how to create simple structures
simple metrics and accountability I mean
this sounds incredibly basic but when I
go in after a business's failed right
when you study on TV the spill in the
Gulf right do you see do you do you
sense simple lines of accountability
people whose metrics were aligned you
know when you go into any crisis in a
residual way that's what I always see
we're big in the water business we've
got a two and half billion dollar water
business and we fundamentally did it
through acquisitions we did about ten or
twelve acquisitions relatively quickly
we liked this space we wanted to be in
it and we we did it more in organic we
did a more energy and organically than
organically about three years ago the
business hit the wall really hit the
wall so I fly down and you know the
first thing I would start you know we
need a crisis how are you organized so
the CEO put the organization's out there
unintelligible you know we had taken all
of these acquisitions and put them in
like a nice neat GE matrix so nobody
knew what their measurements were who
the who they work for you know and they
and they and you know you sit there like
in the first 15 minutes you say we are
screwed you know this is you know and it
metrics not aligned organization chart
unintelligible nobody was accountable
you know one person the CEO might have
been accountable for the P&L but it was
distributed throughout the
organizations so you know anytime you
get that you're going to go through a
leadership change right and you come
back and and you know the person comes
back and says you know I know we wanted
to make it this deep but let's de couple
some of these things and you know three
years later you have real simplicity and
real focus and and and that's something
to always in your own life and career
and in your early jobs is make sure you
know how you're measured if you go into
private equity you know make sure you
know how to set up clear lines of
accountability that are simple and well
understood really critical number five
this is something every school does
poorly and I would my sense is that
Stanford does as well though this is a
great place is we need a generation of
systems systems thinkers you know people
that know how to pull together disparate
thoughts into solutions there's two
problems that I kind of thought while I
was at Co GE that I could have some kind
of impact on one is clean energy and the
other one's affordable healthcare and in
2005 we launched an initiative called
eco imagination and in 2009 we launched
an initiative called health imagination
all of them really addressing how do we
make money for investors by solving big
problems at the same time is energy an
innovation challenge yeah
yeah kind of you know but I can
guarantee an energy there will be really
innovative solutions that never see the
light of day is a public policy problem
you bet
right so when all of your world gets set
by the price of a barrel of oil today
and most of your assets are going to
live 30 or 40 years the only thing that
can bridge those two time horizons is
public policy is energy a manufacturing
challenge you've ahead because unlike
information technology and healthcare to
a certain extent best and breed almost
never wins in energy this is a study of
the second best solution well executed
the second best solution at low cost
almost always Trump's the most
innovative
that's high price so if you're
passionate I don't know how many people
here are going to leave here and go into
an energy related field probably a bunch
of you and you guys are probably
passionate about the science and all
that stuff you better be a systems
thinker you better be a problem solver
because vision ain't going to get you
there and that's something that I find
colleges and business goals have done a
bad job of really training most most
really important things that that matter
really require that kind of discipline
thinking a six
you know the courage and patience to see
a solution through you know to many
people particularly big businesses but
across the board investors things like
that just are just day traders you know
that there's just too many people that
you know doing important new things
really takes time and and the ability to
stick with and fund and innovation and
technology through a cycle over cycle is
really extraordinarily important one of
the places where we put capital a lot of
capital is in you know molecular
diagnostics you know we're a big
diagnostics company we do diagnostic
imaging and life sciences and and
information technology and health we've
got about a twenty billion dollar
healthcare business and so you know
about in 2003 you know we just wanted to
make a real bet that said you know
someday you're going to be able to
screen Alzheimer's and a living patient
work with a work with a drug company
that can [ __ ] the onset of Alzheimer's
and and if you can take the most
difficult symptoms and delay them by
five years that's a 60 billion dollar
savings to the healthcare system what I
just described you is 12 years 12 years
right so you know our investors don't
always like it our employees sometimes
get bored you know but if you want to do
really neat stuff over time it's going
to take this incredible debt you know
vision and incredible dedication to
stick with a generation of
technology will do the jet engine for
the Boeing 787 it's a billion dollar
plus program it'll break even in eight
years maybe something like that so so
the notion to kind of stick with things
and be able to Tibet is something that
really sometimes is frustrating in big
companies because we don't do it enough
said this is what I've learned the hard
way a couple times which is you know I
think really critically important for
you guys as you know a lot of you will
go to work and consulting or how many
people here will go to work in
consulting come on be brave it's really
seriously it's nothing I like
consultants it's a knowing and
understanding you know on and this is
something I've thought about for a long
time knowing and understanding how
things fail now typically it's easy it's
really fun to know when things are
successful what they look what they look
like but knowing the mode of failure of
ideas and projects and and how to get a
good conversation about I guarantee that
nobody on Wall Street or nobody involved
in subprime mortgages really said okay
you know if everything went wrong what
will it cost right I guarantee nobody
ever said two trillion dollars well
somebody said 200 million bucks you know
they didn't do the analysis they didn't
ask but this whole notion of designing
systems to be reliable designing you
know leadership processes for
reliability
that's what financial reform is about
that's that's what the financial crisis
is about that's what the Gulf spill is
about is kind of business and ecosystems
that are just not reliable enough I go
back to my aircraft engines business you
know the FAA right and you want it to be
this way because you we all fly planes
the FAA
when a plane god forbid crashes right
I've got 200 people that work on Erika
there's a business that this is all they
do it's like poetry in motion you know
they go to the side they analyze the
black box they know what happened these
guys know within 24 hours basically
every crash that since I've been CEO
that's taken place it is not that you
want to brag about that but that's a
system that works and and so we're going
to have to build that on a global basis
and lots of different industries and
being a big leader that knows how to ask
not the fun question but the ones around
mode of failure and being willing to dig
and stick to it and ask questions until
you're satisfied that you've had that
kind of that kind of focus is really
really important eight something that I
I were a little bit about your
generation and and it's people have to
know how to manage people that are
different than they are you know you
just too many of you like hanging around
with you you know and and and that's
there's nothing wrong with that but but
you know when I look at some of the
angst that's in the global economy today
you know basically the average American
I'll say because that's where we are
even though we're a global company says
they're angry at Wall Street but really
doesn't know what happens on Wall Street
you know so that's not really why
they're angry they're angry because they
got left behind and they got left behind
because people that are graduating from
this place
fundamentally don't care about creating
jobs and that's why they don't you know
the day you step out of here most
Americans are going to like you because
they think you're affluent and you're
arrogant and you just don't give a [ __ ]
about anything but yourself
and so you know I encouraged you early
in your career and I'm that here you
look how I'm a capitalist so I'm not
here to give you any preaching stories I
say it for your own leadership skills I
would find wait you know you just have
to train yourself to like hourly factory
workers salespeople the people on the
front lines of whatever organization
that you bench chemists and and learn
how to motivate those people and and sit
with them and understand the world
through their eyes and and that's as
important as anything you know you learn
here you know I say this every business
where I go to the class I hated in
business goal was organizational
behavior
hate it I thought it was boring I
thought it was stupid I said like like
when can we get back in finance right
today I never do finance anymore right
all I do is organizational behavior it's
like it's like punishing me for all my
sins
after all this after all this time so so
no no no something about that leaves
from the front you know too few people
are accountable and that's something
that's really important and people have
to you know have to be more well-known
for being in front of their companies
and protecting the reputation and look
this has been a challenge if you were
running anybody in financial services
the day the Lehman Brothers went
bankrupt let me tell you you've taken
some shots I sure have you know it's
just you just weren't gonna there was no
place to hide when the storm started
right so the difference is if you don't
you know I got tougher through the whole
thing about fighting for my company
being willing to go and protect and be
accountable and stand up for what GE was
about and people don't always love us
right but but we were able to maintain a
reputation respect because we're
accountable you know and I just think
that's a that's a that's a whole thing
now most of you look and I think you
should you should want to go make a lot
of money
you absolutely should there is nothing
wrong with that nothing at all there's a
few points in your career when you
shouldn't make a lot of money right
there's a few points in your career when
you got to step back and say you know
what I earned a lot of money this year I
deserve a lot of money this year
I like making a lot of money but I'm not
going to take a bonus why because I've
been around a long time I have
perspective I have context and I'm
accountable for reputation whether it's
deserved or not and so my message to you
is not you know I want you to be
aggressive and competitive and
capitalistic and wanting to make a lot
of money
but I guarantee in the next thirty years
there's going to be like two or three or
four years where you will have earned a
lot of money and it's your
there's no Washington law there is no
board of directors that's going to tell
you when the time is right to step back
and say not this year not now that's got
to come from you and that's why that's
what people call authenticity that's
what people call you know kind of
accountability and you should want to be
that way
lastly it always helps to be a leader if
you actually like people you know it's a
you know it is one of those things
that's quite weird I worked for a lot of
bosses in my career who didn't just
didn't like people you know the last one
actually did I have to say you know so
he was a Welch but but you know simple
things you know about treating people
with respect and wanted to get the most
out of them actually actually go a long
ways so those are kind of five or ten
things that we try to incorporate into
the way we train our leaders and and the
way we think about leadership I actually
like I say about every five years we try
to upgrade you know you have to have a
long enough gestation on how what you're
training your managers so that you can
drill it in your organization but you
can't stay stale from a standpoint of
what people are thinking about so I'd
say we kind of run in a four or five
year cycle about what we're what we're
trying to how we're trying to upgrade
leadership and we're trying to teach
people so that's my that's my that's my
take on leadership you know good leader
in the end what is that what is this CEO
do I think you know basically I have two
jobs you know I Drive change you know
fundamentally the leader of a company
like GE
you know my job is to really is to
really drive change
and to develop other people you know
you've got you what you are solely
responsible for the culture and the
values that permeate permeate the
company so let me turn you talk about
whatever or whatever you wanna talk
about yeah
first of all thanks thanks for the talk
my question is I can you talk a little
bit about your early career said you
started with G in 1982 and how you
managed a career if you had a vision
what your thoughts on leadership were
and with some of the milestones or
obstacles you may have faced especially
in a big company like GE yeah so I
looked at it as like a five year so I
went to work in 82 and I was trying our
plastics business and I basically my
first job was to be kind of a product
manager to sell plastic into instrument
panels of cars and this was in the early
80s and cafe standards had just been
passed in Detroit and this whole
conversion from metal to plastic was was
quite significant and so I was the I
would go sell a product called Norrell
into pickup trucks on on cars and I had
a kind of a five-year five-year vision
and and wanted to you know kind of get
into sales you know in other words what
I wanted to start doing was being a you
know broadening my capabilities so more
from marketing to sales and I think
early your career it's really about
getting good at something you know being
recognized for you know I was a good
good sales and marketing person and I
kind of grew up to the plastics business
and I tried to go after tough jobs and I
tried to I try to get known early on as
being a good manager so I people like
workers you know I wanted people to like
working for me and relating to so I went
from there to running a big sales force
in the organization I had probably half
the u.s. from a sales standpoint so I I
tried to model my first five years on
getting good at something and then and
then from there becoming deep and then
in 1988 or 89 so I've been there maybe
78 years given a presentation to Larry
paucity in the plastics business and I
was doing pretty well and what
recognized and then a call comes with a
and my search is is Jack Welch you know
and I said Josh yeah I thought it was
one of my sales friends who was just you
know busting my ass on my kids so he
said look Jeff you're doing great we
love you in plastics but we're having
this incredible compressor failure in
our appliance business and I need an
outside I need a young talent outside
set of eyes I know you don't know
anything about it but but I need a
change right now and somebody that's got
the passion and and he said and I don't
like any of your bosses out there you
don't work from them you work for me
hangs up the phone so I'm I'm like 33
years old now same thing this is what's
going on here right and that job
probably made Mike it was a brutal job
for three years it was it was so tough
but that was my break and you know I
wouldn't be CEO today if he hadn't
reached down which I try to do and gave
me a high-risk high-reward a job and and
so that's so so you know you kind of got
if you got to have a couple five-year
plans and I don't think you can ever
dream about being the CEO of G or P&G or
something like that it's just too weird
you know so much like so much luck
involved and I think what you do is you
build if you want a company life which
is you build a great foundation of
accomplishment and networking and and
things have a way you know at higher
levels of companies are really taking
care of themselves and if you don't do
it here you can do it someplace else but
I stay focused coming out here in your
first five years and and it's a and do
what you you know kind of like don't
play for the triple bank right I see a
lot of business cool kids and say okay
I'm gonna I want to run G someday right
so because I want to run G someday I'm
going to go to work at BCG no maybe but
I just realized
I know the guy that runs BCG I'm quite
fond of him we are as different our
experiences our capabilities are that is
different as is humanly possible right
so I think that's what I call like the
triple banker you know I'm going to I'm
going to I say if you want to join
venture capital joint venture capital
going to probably you want to join a
company join a company 20 when you come
back to your 20 year reunion successful
people be successful and and the
pathways will be wildly different Jamie
Dimon was my good friend and business
will we've been friends for 30 years he
went to work for Sandy while you know I
went to sell plastic and instrument
panels we booked it okay you know it
kind of in the end at all it all worked
out but our pathways I moved nine times
you know he say New York but were great
pals we we all do we do our thing
differently but we do it effectively I
hope and and that's that's what happens
but fall in love with your job let it
let it go don't don't worry about what
your classmates are doing fall in love
and let it let it happen a lot of
questions yeah right there now we get
the mic to you of it
thanks for coming Jaffa speaking of Jack
Welch you had some pretty big shoes to
fill back when you took over which
you've done pretty successfully that's
wondering if you can talk a little bit
about that transition phase and how you
went about implementing your own
leadership style and in the process
establishing your own legacy og
so I'd say if given a choice it's a lot
easier to follow a failure so that'd be
just uh just hey just report some advice
if you if you get that choice a
leadership is really a one-act play you
know and and I never really thought
about my job in terms of following Jack
Welch and the trick when you follow
somebody famous is you got to drive
change every day without ever pretending
anything was ever wrong and so it takes
self-confidence and it takes it takes
time and you don't need to obviously you
know draw the differentiation between
the two of you you know I learned a lot
from Jack I think Jack was a great CEO
and and it's just that you know 2010 is
is different from 1997 as it is from
1927 and and and there's just really no
comparison to the worlds we're in it
doesn't mean that some of the
fundamentals of business like like
integrity and performance aren't the
same but look in your life you're going
to follow some successful bosses and I
think the trick is to do it your way
keep your mouth shut you know just just
say hey there's we have no problems
really fundamentally and and let let
your own pathway work and in the end
that's what people want that's what our
board wanted that's what our team wanted
is just you know people want leadership
change in a world where leadership has
no shelf life and you just have to go
with it yeah we're you mentioned the
idea of reversing innovation before so
my question is do you think it is a main
trend for the global companies to
develop the technologies and products in
the developing countries in future and
do you see any challenges or
this kind of innovation approach so
we've talked a lot about this thing
called reverse innovation you know
companies like GE have been in you know
globally dispersed for 20 years in some
cases but certainly 10 years a lot of
cases and we have big research centers
in in in China and India and Brazil and
all over the world so when I tell what I
talk about is you know we all started
selling basically American products
globally and then we localized
manufacturing and you know kind of step
by step by step but now we have great
engineering and marketing teams in China
and India and what we're trying to do is
understand the business models that get
created in different regions of the
world so that as change takes place in
the developed world we can pull the
technology or the or the business model
and become better let's say in Chicago
based on what we learned in China now
one of these we've done in China and
Health Care's maybe the best example of
this one of these we've done in China is
we got a huge health care business in
China we we develop almost all of our
own products there and so you know
that's where the $500,000 MRE is that's
where our V scan ultrasound which is
really an ultrasound with a PDA and
these are products that have markedly
lower price points but you know could be
sold to a there's two thousand hospitals
in the u.s. that don't have an mr
scanner primarily rural hospitals can be
sold to a rural hospital that has never
been able to afford that at a different
price point so that's what we mean by by
reverse innovation India is different
you know what I find most fascinating
about India is that it's it's not just
different technology but it's a
different business model you know and so
how can we study the way to let's say
healthcare information technology's done
in India and bring that back to the u.s.
that becomes a an established principle
as well now you know your world
basically guys my age basically could
move work anywhere they wanted anytime
they wanted with no consequence so in
the generation of American business
leaders are more less my age
we were able to do whatever we wanted to
do with no consequence that's changed
that's changed the advantage of a multi
business company like GE is we can do a
little bit of stuff everywhere and so if
if all we did was move all of our
technology and all of our innovation to
India or China that would make it very
unpopular with our customers in the u.s.
in the garden and the government so the
trick is to be a drone up as a company
to do a lot of different things in a lot
of different places and try to optimize
your technology base and your cost base
to be able to do those things and that's
what you know that's what we've prided
ourselves and being good at and that's
what we really are trying to be good at
today you know you add to that you know
we've driven lean through the company
for almost 20 years now you know kind of
lean manufacturing techniques so we can
make a refrigerator with an hour and a
half of labor if you can if you have
really weaned through your cycle time
you can almost start making things any
place you want to relatively
cost-efficient regardless of difference
in wages and things like that so you
know that's that's what we learned so
the last thing you know just going to
the person we're honoring here today you
know sometimes there's we started
Genpact gym packs a great company in its
own day that was kind of reverse
innovation really what we did is we took
call centers we had the United States
and we replicated them in India with
better people at a lower cost I mean you
know when you get when you get that you
know when you're replacing people that
have a high school education with people
that are PhDs who you pay less sometimes
that works you know that's that's a so
but you know I was convinced that we
would choke to impact if we just kept it
as a G business and sometimes you got to
recognize what business models we can do
a good job at what is a good G business
and where are we better off letting
things letting things go other questions
yeah right why don't you shout it out
and I'll repeat it because they're never
going to get a mic to you
thank you rightly referenced the fact
that many of us during the meet here and
doing very small orientations your
investment managers and stars that we
start work go to help Ron guess my
question is you know sitting is the
leader of the pyramid training ground
for leaders of large organizations what
can we learn from GE those of us who
want to get small companies so look I
think it's a great question the question
is small companies what can you learn
from big companies there's a lot of
things that are very transportable right
in other words I think the the idea on
focus the idea on how to motivate people
relating you know relating to a variety
of different people you can really learn
that really well in GE and you might not
get that from a 50 person startup or
things like that but there's other ways
that there's bad things to learn from
big companies as well you know like like
if you're running a startup forget about
Six Sigma for about ten years you know
really it's just you're going to waste
money it's not why people it's not why
you exist and so the trick is keeping
keeping the things that are good and
really you know you and I are alike you
know I want to grow you want to grow I
want to see ideas hit the streets you
want to see ideas hit the street so
we've tried to make a company that
aspirationally isn't that horribly
different than a start-up you know
there's differences you know you come to
GE you work for me right if you want to
boss don't come to work for GE you know
in other words or if you don't want to
boss don't come to work for GE if you
want to be your own boss to it a startup
you know I'm my own banker that's my
advantage trade if you don't want to go
out beg for money
join GE I'm the bank you only have to
convince really a couple people let's
start up different we've tried to make
GE a good convener I don't think it has
to be either/or you know we are a big
collaborator with kleiner perkins at our
global research center about every other
month we'll have big venture capital
companies on mass come and share ideas
and talk about things we probably have
100 meaningful equity stakes and startup
companies and in those cases we try to
bring to them management practices that
will work for them but keep away things
that
that that aren't going to work you know
we we have a solar company we now in 60%
of its in Colorado just startup you know
we we don't really touch it that much
but when it comes time to have to go to
the next commercial scale that's going
to cost 250 million bucks on that day
we're good you know that that's that's a
so the trick is knowing what works and
what doesn't work and and what things
can be helpful to a company that's just
starting up but look I have a I have
immense respect and a lot of time for
the venture capital community I really
do
I've tried to develop good relationships
and I do think that is a strength in
this country that is second to none and
I'm try to make GE a good partner to
those firms yeah thanks for coming Jeff
you mentioned energy um and G's got a
lot of press recently for supporting
their climate bill released this month
and a lot of people project that the
carbon market will grow to be true
trillion dollars the world's largest
commodity so I'm interested in knowing
what you think is a likely outcome of
the of this slow shift and any
opportunities for innovation that you
see there so I got into this game on
mass probably in 2004 having no real
environmental credibility personally
more as a company you know in other
words I've never camped really you know
I've I've never
I've never planted a flower and I
stopped mowing my own grass a long time
ago you know so I'm not a date I'm not a
nature lover but in 2004 Ana by the way
I spent 12 years of my career in our
plastics business where you know and you
just grew to dislike environmentalists
really fun of Italy they you know there
there was a healthy there was a healthy
angst between people in that industry in
the environmental community and in 2004
I think or 2003 you know we were sitting
through our strategy sessions and and
about five or six Jean businesses we're
all working on energy efficiency or
carbon reduction you know and so I sat
in in you know kind of sat through all
those presentations and said gosh we
ought to try to pull this together as a
corporate initiative and see if we can
really uh put a notch up the Rd up the
public presence up the Marketing up the
customer engagement and we did that in
launched in 2005 and we had about that
we had you know kind of a third party
that certified these technologies each
of which would reduce the their
predecessors carbon footprint by 25% so
we started with 17 products we now have
93 products we started with about five
billion dollars in revenue we'll hit 20
billion dollars revenue this year so you
know our thesis was Green is green
we run GE under the Kyoto Protocol
so we reduced our own carbon footprint
it reduced visibility carbon the Kyoto
Protocol and so that's how we got into
it so when we started we we created
three teams one studied public policy
one study the science and we had kind of
a Red Team Blue team study the science
and one team argue that global warming
was a hoax the other team argued that
that global warming was a technical fact
caused by man and we try to we try to be
you know relatively bipartisan about it
and then one team talk to our customers
write our big utilities or Airlines or
things like that to try to frame so we
we did probably nine months of pre-work
before we launched in a big way in 2005
one of these if you're in the energy
business for a long time you know that
it's a lot about innovation but public
policy is
you're just not going to you know it's
just if you look today probably the
lowest incremental cost and the power
generation field is nuclear power right
probably the cleanest and lowest cost
all these plants are twenty five thirty
years old and the CEOs that launched
these plants twenty five or thirty years
ago all got fired they were the biggest
problems they were horrible they're the
regulator's would let them get finished
you know so so the cheapest electricity
today was placed wherever he got fired
twenty five years ago and when you see
that you know that nothing's really
going to happen unless you have some
form of energy policy now if you can
have energy policy a lot to have energy
security at ought to have job creation
ought to have a lot of things but one of
the aspects needs to be a price for
carbon
you know the vagaries of the market are
just too circumstantial and you need to
be able to invest against some kind of
constancy in price for carbon you can do
that through a tax a tax is simpler
easier to administer and some would
argue the best way to go
environmentalist don't like it because
it has no certainty around it another
part is to do cap and trade and that's
been you know very complicated in Europe
it creates a lot of your oxy to get it
done but it is certain in terms of where
you go I'm convinced we need one of
those you know we we've been on record
to support energy legislation and is
realized legislation that has Kappa
trade in it I have very low hopes for
what will happen this year just given
the political environment and things
like that but look guys you know here's
the this is your own choice in your life
because it you know look any one of you
guys can do my job if you graduate from
Stanford business goal it's not about IQ
you are smart enough to do my job let's
just get that out of the way the
questions do you want to you know do you
do you want to and one of these weird
things about life is to do something you
have to do something I mean it's one of
these strange things so so here we are
today right
we're sitting there and you know we're
in the only gas business so I'm not I'm
not being critical but we're sitting
there looking at this this environmental
really difficult I mean I don't know
where it'll go but boy it is this is one
of the toughest things I've seen in my
career
what's going on the Gulf at any time we
are doing nothing zero on energy some
people give them speeches on this other
mumbo-jumbo nothing as a country on
energy future so I think that's wrong
that's wrong and and my and my corner of
the world GE is going to do stuff we're
going to up it you know we say we're
going to spend ten billion dollars an
hour and day between oh five and ten we
did it we're going to do 15 billion
between ten and fifteen so we're going I
don't know if it's going to be in the US
or China or Turkey we're going to go
wherever we need to go to be effective
but we you know as this country has to
be looking self in the mirror and be
really ashamed of where we are today in
energy and and which is you know we
could be critical BP if we want as a
country but boy you're not doing
anything so you don't impress me you
know as a citizen I'm I'm quite I think
it's very hard yeah so as per Garth's
introduction of Roenick three of the
things that he really cared about or
travel relationships and spirituality so
I was wondering how those show up in
your life is a leader and as a person so
you know travel is I think actually if
you want to run a company like GE you
have to be a globalist and so you have
to live a life that sees things and
touches people and is open to people you
can read a book on China you know you
can read 30 books on China that's why I
wouldn't read one you know if you
in China go and spend hundreds of days
not just in Beijing and Shanghai but in
30 other cities over 25 you know look
I've been going to China since 1984 I
have visited probably 30 cities I've
started two businesses from scratch done
joint ventures with the government I've
I know private business people you want
to be CEO GE that's the path you know or
any other companies so that's travel
what was the second one so business is
really a study of relationships you know
I my own view is that people use the
word you know in business if you can't
make somebody more money you're not a
good partner so I have kind of a linear
view on what it means to be a good
friend in business you know to be to be
a good friend in business you better you
better be able to see things through the
other person's point of view I'm on
President Obama's Advisory Board I voted
for McCain I'm a Republican but the
president wanted to reach out and have
different voices when I go and serve the
president my role isn't to say here's
what you should do my role is to say
here's what I would do if I were you
here's what I would do if I were you do
you guys get the difference you know one
has the benefit of context and
relationship versus the other one is
just giving a lecture so relationships
you learn your own new ones like
spirituality if you want to do anything
important people going to hate you more
days than they like you people are going
to not like you more days than they like
you and unless you can take a good punch
and do it with a smile on your face you
went to the wrong place you you chose
the wrong vocation you ought to be in
Divinity School or something like that
so you're going to have to have deep
understanding of yourself you're going
to have to have other things in your
life that are important than than just
your job
and you're going to have to have a sense
that perseverance and an optimism and
you know if you asked me to describe
myself I'd say I'm a I'm a tough-minded
optimist
that's Jeff ml I'm tough minded and then
I like facts I like data I like doing
stuff I don't mind taking risks but I'm
an optimist because I like trying things
you know pessimists are just minimalist
they're just they're just horrible
minimalist you know that's not I I want
to try things and do things and see
where the world goes and you know that
what I would describe to people when
they come to GE is look you're going to
be the front seat of history
you kind of work to gee you know we're
not a perfect company but I guarantee it
where it's happening what's going on
we're going to be somewhere close to
where hit business history taking place
that is the best calling card I can give
for GE other questions yeah Jeff oh just
other question you know some of the
lessons learn if you could share with us
some of the lessons learned and
challenges faced during the recent
financial crisis within your management
team look I think the the there's a lot
of different nuanced things you can
answer on on the financial crisis from
both a system and individual but again I
come back to listening harder being more
focused on all the risks in the downside
you know again we we did studies you
know the McKinsey study stuff like that
but I think companies just didn't do
enough tough challenging what if this
goes wrong and listen to naysayers
enough so you know that's that's how
we've tried to change inside inside GE
in that inside the crisis take one more
bonus question
does that hand up way the back will make
this for last Kashi how do you think
about I mean you talked about kind of
taking the right risks and how do you
think about which businesses to enter at
what point and how to exit I don't know
if there were some specific processes or
ways that you thought about that as a
leader within GE and so I think when you
run a couple like GE you know a big
multi business company you need to be
very tough minded about the entrance and
the exits so we have a point of view
about what we're good at you know what's
our core business model what does a good
G business have we try to study
businesses that go through transitions
you know like like I was a plastics guy
a star maker I sold the business three
or four years ago because the industry
itself had gone through terrible transit
you know really horrible transition so
we you know we could see that so we try
to study big trends our own core
competency and then secular deviations
that tell us what business we like and
what businesses we should be
transitioning away from so today we're
the world's biggest infrastructure
company and and one of the bigger
commercial finance companies we like
that mix of businesses but that wasn't
the company that I took over in 2001
it's very different than that company
you know intermedia you know it's it's
just in the case of that specific
decision it was what was the best use of
capital in the GE context and I saw so
many investing opportunities and our
energy and healthcare business that I
just wasn't convinced that we were going
to take the capital and put it into
media over the long term and I and and I
was convinced that the way the industry
was going you either were going to have
to be a consolidator or you were going
to Road shareholder value so so that's
why we did the joint venture with
Congress timing you can't pick you know
in other words I you know if you're in
if you're in private equity timing is
everything really if you're going to
have a kind of a five-year hold or
two-year hold or seven-year hold in the
case of gee
yeah I think we have to be better at
business model match than picking the
right time
look I but look when I when I see the
Euro do what it's done the last couple
weeks you know the companies got maybe a
hundred billion dollars of cash today I
look and say where can we swoop you know
I call the BD guys and we look at our
game boards you know every company in
Europe that we've been looking at you
know why not if it's on strategy I would
do it if wasn't on strategy but sitting
around at this moment of time with 100
but you know almost harder Bennett cash
is not a bad hand to have you know right
now so that's this may be this may be a
good time
look have fun of your careers and
you